Excited about our conversation today
with Khan Academy's head of
engineering VP of engineering,
Marta Kosarchyn,
but before we get into that,
I will give my standard
announcement a reminder to everyone
that Khan Academy is a not for profit
that we only exist because
of philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
A special thanks to several
corporations that stepped up
a couple of months ago,
when they found out
that we were running at a
deficit even before COVID.
And then with all of the
things we've been trying to do
in response to COVID, our
deficit has only increased.
Special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly and Novartis
and many other foundations
and individual donors of all
levels who make this possible.
I will say that we still
are running at a deficit
and digging into reserves.
So if at any scale, if
you're in a position to help,
please think about making a donation.
So with that, I am
excited to introduce Marta
- So, Marta, thanks for joining.
And I'll remind everyone who's watching
on Facebook or YouTube,
please put questions you have
for myself or Marta, on
the message boards below.
We have team members, who are
gonna be surfacing questions,
and they can really be a questions about
anything and everything.
But we're gonna be talking a
lot about just Marta's journey
to how she got to Khan Academy.
So it could be about career advice,
especially if you're trying to think about
going into technical field or engineering,
but it literally could be about anything.
It could be life advice, it
could be how we do engineering,
really any topic is within bounds.
So Marta, maybe a good place to start.
You're the CTO and VP of engineering.
What do those titles mean?
What do you do here at Khan Academy?
What do they mean generally
in most organizations?
- Yeah, I mean, generally
in most organizations,
and at Khan Academy, it's
leading the engineering team,
which is the team that builds our product,
our Khan Academy website,
and provides for learning experiences
that encapsulate the content
that we have available
for our users and helps them
on their learning journey
and all of the things
that you often talk about
on daily homeroom.
So we build that.
And so we have to choose the
technology that's appropriate
for us to not only build an
appropriate learning experience,
but build it in a way that
provides reasonable performance
and stability and reliability.
Because that's our
promise, that's our service
to the organization is that we will
we will take care of the platform,
we basically steward the
platform and make the choices
that will
get our product out there.
- Yeah, and you know, explain to,
I think a lot of people have
a perception that you know,
it is true Khan Academy
was started by me in a walk in closet
actually was this walk
in closet that I'm in now
so it's still that part
is still has held true.
There's a silent walk in closet someplace.
It's very nice one, as you can tell,
it has a bookshelf and
has some natural lighting.
But you know, people don't realize
that we're over 200 person organization,
we have an over 80
person engineering team.
And so people think, Well, you know,
I know Khan Academy has videos,
you have some exercises.
This is a major organization.
What is requiring us to have
such a, not only a large team,
but a deep team, we have
some of the world's experts
in a lot of the areas of
technology and infrastructure.
What is the focus of that
engineering team that you lead?
- Yeah, that's a great
question for us to talk about
because I'll share a story
when I shared with folks that
I was coming to Khan Academy,
and they said, Well,
what kind of engineering
do you need a Khan Academy?
Because so many people think, Oh, well,
there are some videos right on YouTube,
that you can go watch.
And so I hope I was helpful
in kind of getting the word
out there to come to our site
and our product and to enjoy.
Not only the videos, but the articles
and the exercises in particular,
and the mastery mechanics
and all of the things that
we provide for learners
and for teachers and for parents.
So we have yes, over 80 engineers,
and we have a really, really
spectacular engineering team.
We're so fortunate to have
incredibly skilled
engineers that work here,
have come because of the
mission that you found itself
to provide a free world class
education for anyone anywhere,
and folks come here
who are dedicated to it
and who do really spectacular
work on the product.
So we are building, like I
said, learning experiences,
we're building teaching experiences,
and the engineers are building the site.
So yeah, there's a lot of us
who are very good.
- Just to double underline
or triple underline
what you're saying, I don't
think people realize that,
you know, when Khan Academy
had a few thousand people
using it every month, yeah,
maybe it could operate,
you know, on a shoestring.
I would say still
operating on a shoestring
relative to its scale.
Obviously, it's the budget
of a large High School
and reaches over 100
million students every year.
But to your point, you know, we have to
keep it up and running 24/7,
we have to make sure it's performant.
You know, just the data that
we're storing and once again,
we only store data in service to students
to make the learning experience better
or to understand efficacy.
That by itself is gargantuan.
We have, you know, millions
of dollars in server costs
that we have to keep running
as efficiently as possible.
And to your point,
our product is more
nuanced and complicated
than I think most people realize.
We have official SAT practice,
we have subjects in grades
from pre k all the way through college,
we have multiple modalities,
we have teacher aspects,
tools to it worth keeping
track of everything.
We have students things
and so you can imagine
just even keeping track
of and the game mechanics
and the state for 100 million plus people.
It's no joke, and we're just
kind of glazing the surface.
So, before we get into,
there's actually a lot of good
questions that are coming in
on Facebook and YouTube.
Before we get into it, Marta, you know,
just share a little bit of your journey
of how you got to Khan Academy, you know,
and start as far back as you like.
I think that's what's
unique about homeroom.
I think people are intrigued
in knowing folks paths in life.
- Okay, well we'll go far back.
So I grew up in Chicago.
My parents were immigrants.
I'm a first generation American and
I think I've shared in
two truths in the light
So you know, this cell that
one of the things I always
kind of use is the fact that I
didn't learn to speak English
until I went to school.
And so that was my very early journey.
Coming to Khan Academy is
something that I've often said
is sort of coming full
circle because I started off
loving math and studying math.
And I have a couple of degrees in math.
As a female in particular,
my age going through
and being a Math major and
going to graduate school
the questions that I always got.
Well, why aren't you in Math Ed?
because you know, you should be a teacher.
And I was very adamant about the fact
that I didn't wanna be a teacher.
I wanted to just study math.
And it wasn't until grad school I was a TA
that I fell in love with teaching.
And I think a big insight for me there
which I know you experience
all the time Sal,
given the content that you do
is just because I was learning so much
every time I have to just
really had to talk about
the same concept even in
classes and they'd repeat
obviously for grad students as a TA.
I've learned something new, right?
There's something else I'd discovered
some physical phenomenon
that I could relate it to.
So anyway, I did that for a while,
I was always in applied mathematics
and I got really interested in coding
because I had to do coding to do my work.
And I eventually studied
computer science as well
and came out to Silicon Valley for a bit
to try it out with HP
and I ended up spending a long
time almost 15 years at HP
and I have worked in the software business
I came originally doing CAD algorithms,
still leveraging my math background a lot
and then moved to distributed systems
and really worked long term and
distributed systems research
at HP Labs and working on
some of the first products
for broadband distributed
systems on the internet.
Obviously, the advent of the Internet
It's something that I experienced.
And anyway, coming to Khan Academy
Finally, in my software
development journey
and leading engineering teams,
has been kind of like a dream come true
because it's sort of full circle.
I was a big fan of Khan
Academy for a long time.
And the fact that I could join and help
with the engineering experience
leadership that I've had
and contribute to the mission that way
is pretty special to me.
- And at least a question from YouTube,
AZ asks, "Why did you choose
to work with Khan Academy?"
And I'll add to that question,
because one of the questions I got
in the early days of Khan Academy
when I wanted to set it up
and I did set it up as a not for profit,
is I got a lot of skepticism
that you will not be able to
attract top technical talent,
especially in the Bay Area.
We're literally a few miles down the road
from Google from Facebook from Apple.
You know, we pay well,
but we can't give stock
because we don't have any.
Anyone watching has as much
stock as you and I have
In Khan Academy.
So you know, you are someone that could be
the CTO at nearly any
company in the valley.
And, you know, and I don't
wanna make you tempted,
but you could be making
millions of dollars every year.
Why?
I'll just, you know, that's
just adding to the question
from AZ on YouTube.
Why Khan Academy?
- Why Khan Academy?
It's a great question.
Well, first of all, I
was a Khan Academy fan
for a long time.
And Sal, I know when I
think interviewed with you,
I shared my stories about like,
Boy, when I discovered Sal's style site,
it was basically people would
always ask me to explain,
like math things to them.
And I said, you know,
there's this guy (laughs)
that does so much better
job than I ever did.
You really should just
kind of look at these.
And so anyway, I was a big fan.
And so I feel very privileged
to come to contribute to the mission.
Now, I had some trepidation
about building an engineering team,
especially when I came
we've scaled very quickly
in the three years that I've been here.
The team was less than half
the size that it is today.
And our growth has been major, I mean,
just this spring, because
of the COVID-19 situation,
of course in schools
closing our usage grew,
as you've talked about quite a bit
250% very quickly.
Which, as an aside is
something I'm very, very proud
of our team about the fact
that we were able to sustain
that kind of growth and not
cause hiccups for our learners
when they desperately needed us.
And when we had all of
those amazing schedules
and materials, to serve up
for families and students
who were just all of a sudden at home,
and everybody was scrambling to adjust.
Anyway, I did have some trepidation
about hiring at a nonprofit.
And I can say that this
is the strongest team
that I've ever had anywhere.
Not making this Up.
This is absolutely the truth.
We have amazing folks here
who came for the mission
who come for the mission every day,
and are also spectacularly
talented and focused
on this mission and the lever that we have
in today's world with all of the events
that are going on today,
to be able to work somewhere right now.
And we're all working
very hard, long hours,
we can talk about some of our projects.
I don't know that I could do it
if I wasn't working on
this mission, to be honest,
and really thinking about
the impact that we have
every single day on so many people.
You know, as you know,
when we started exploding,
I was working very long days
and I said to a bunch of my friends,
You know, I couldn't do this anymore.
If I was like in the corporate world,
but at Khan Academy,
the reward is pretty major.
- Yeah, you know, I think
you're an example of it
and everyone on the team
proudly at Khan Academy.
I remember when I was working
as an analyst at a hedge fund,
which is a very, I guess you could say
money driven industry by definition,
that's all it's driven by really.
I remember reading a research study
that said that actually the
top performers in a field,
they aren't motivated by money.
They do need enough money to
live and support their family
and buy a house and go on vacations
and send their kids to college
and that type of thing.
But beyond that kind of sufficient level,
they care much more about
impact, challenging work
and being able to work
with other aligned people.
And you know, the fact
that folks like yourself,
and the entire team at
Khan Academy have joined
I think, is evidence.
I was skeptical about when
I read that paper (laughs)
when I was very coin operated.
But I think it's absolutely true.
- Yeah.
- So from YouTube Lorina says,
"Marta, what are your passions,
your true passions at work
and out of it?"
- My true passions at work are,
First of all, it is my team.
So leading the team,
which is more than just the
technical work that we have,
but really the work that we do on creating
a cohesive organization.
We updated our engineering
principles about a year ago
and the team worked on them
and we're very proud of those two
because it says a lot
about the kind of people
that we are and the way that
we want to treat each other
at the organization at work always
and the way that we want
to focus on the quality
of what we deliver to our users
is very impact.
And so I'm very passionate about that.
Building the team and having a strong team
of folks who are happy
and I really miss being in the office,
during shelter in place
really, really miss
being in the office because I'm somebody
who long ago learned back at HP
about management by wandering around
and Imma wander around
and love to stop and chat with everybody.
And I do and that's an
important part of my day.
So I'm very passionate about that.
And the other thing I'm
very, very passionate about
is delivering for our users.
So I can be very driven
by the results execution,
which for us means quickly
and with high quality,
delivering new learning experiences,
new teaching experiences
and things for parents
a small talk, you talked
about the test prep
so many experiences that
we know are a big lever
in today's world.
- And just to, you know,
ask Lorina's question again,
and, you know, Marta isn't just giving
a diplomatic introduce
and having a privilege.
(laughs) I love it.
You know, you said everything about work
and obviously that sounds good to me.
But obviously, you
know, we pride ourselves
on making sure people here
have full lives and I mean,
I also have trouble sometimes
extracting myself from work
because it's a passion but you know,
what other things? (laughs)
- What other things?
Yes, And my family will be
very disappointed (laughs)
that I started with the word response.
But obviously my family
is important to me.
My husband and my daughter.
I have a daughter that I'm very proud of
is clerking on the US Court
of Appeals in Washington DC
right now and is a big part of my life
and teaches me a lot
about the culture of today
and my culture of her age, and
which is very helpful for me,
in terms of my organizational knowledge.
And my husband, who's a biochemist,
we are all kind of systems, people,
we think a lot of abstract
kind of system stuff
from, you know, do nerdy things.
My husband and I are doing
a lot of jigsaw puzzles
playing cribbage you
know, stuff like that.
Up until a few years ago,
I was very passionate,
I have to say this because All my friends
if they ever see this will say,
what about beach volleyball
because I played beach
volleyball for many, many years,
and that was my biggest
passion outside of work.
But my knees aren't really
loving that (laughs)
anymore, (laughs)
not so much.
- No, that's a little known
fact about Khan Academy
that we could probably feel the
pretty mean beach volleyball
or volleyball team between
you and then Jenny Lee,
who's our president and COO.
Y'all would be the the core of the team.
I suspect there's there's a few others
that could contribute as well.
So there's a couple of questions here
that I think are pretty
interesting and maybe related.
So Posad Tota asks, from YouTube,
What is the hardest part
about being at Khan Academy?
I haven't gotten that question before,
but it's an interesting one.
And then there's another, he
also asked a similar question,
how does the pandemic affect Khan Academy
that could be internally or externally.
I'd love your take on
what's hard about this job
and how's it changed with the pandemic?
- Yeah, that's a really
interesting question.
What's hard about this job?
I don't wanna sound like
a Pollyanna, but honestly,
this is like the funnest
job I've ever had.
So I'm just gonna say
that I love what I do.
I love the people that I work with.
And I believe every day
I am so reinforced for me
about the impact that
we're having on the world.
So it's really hard to say what's hard.
What's hard is that there's a lot to do.
What's hard is that we are
at a stage of our growth,
where we are working on a project
that we have codenamed Goliath,
which we have posted about in our blogs.
And it's called Goliath
because we are basically moving
our back end server monolith
of about 800,000 lines of code
from Python two to services
based architecture
Written in gold.
So it's big and it's going into go.
So Goliath is hard.
We have a fantastic team
who's doing a great job on it.
But it is a hard, hard thing to do.
As one of my leaders on the team
that manages the platform says,
it's like, we're still flying the plane.
And it's kind of all in pieces,
but we're still keeping all
the passengers on the plane
and flying the plane.
Or I say, it's kind of like
switching out the foundation
in from under your house,
the entire foundation
while you're living in the house.
- Well, there's a party in the house
- And using all the functions.
Well, there's a party in
the house and a pandemic,
by the way, so everybodyis in the house
all the time.
- I know exactly, I mean, I
you know, just to add to that,
I think one of the things
that I found difficult
sometimes about this job
is almost any other job
when you're kind of really
worked up about something
or you want something to be done right,
You can kind of go home, it's like,
well, it doesn't really matter
if I lose this argument,
or, you know,
the company will sell
databases or whatever. (laughs)
And I used to work at
Oracle, a great company,
but that's how I felt about it sometimes,
and that would make me
but at Khan Academy,
whenever I feel like
Well, what's the big deal?
Oh, the big deal is tens
of millions of people
might not be able to learn (laughs)
- That's right.
- So you lose a little more.
And how has the pandemic affected, you
and how we've been able
to work and, you know,
and the things we're working
on from your point of view?
- Yeah, that's a great question, too.
I alluded to part of the answer earlier
what I talked about
missing being in the office
because we're sheltering in
place in Santa Clara County,
and we're all working from home.
And so that has been hard for me
because I am a wanderer rounder
and people person even
though we have a large,
remote set of workers, and
engineers in particular,
and so we're very good at remote working
actually at Khan Academy, it's hard for me
because it's nice to see at
least part of my team every day,
and other folks in other functions
at Khan Academy every day.
So that's hard.
Some things have been easier.
So instead of in the morning,
instead of having to rush
and get in the shower and get dressed,
and then spend 35 or
40 minutes in the car,
driving to the office,
I can now enjoy my
morning meditation sitting
and kind of be a lot
more focused and attuned
when I sit down at my desk.
So for me personally, I'm very fortunate
because I'm continuing
to work and we are able
to get our groceries,
so we've been very fortunate,
and I'm very cognizant about a lot of
what my family's been
doing during the pandemic
is, in fact, trying to look out for where
we can have a positive impact
even outside of Khan Academy,
but where we can contribute and volunteer
and help folks because
the pandemic's much harder
for a lot of people than it is for us.
- Yeah, and then you mentioned,
I talked about meditation a lot
and probably more than people
want me to hear about it.
But I'm curious, do you do meditate
and what got you started with that
and what do you feel it does for you?
- Yeah, well, what got me
started for It was a tough time
that I went through
with a health situation
and really tough anxiety time.
And so it really was more
instrumental at the time
like this is a tool that can help me
because this is so incredibly
difficult to go through.
And then it's really been kind
of a key part of something
that I've done a lot of
personal growth through frankly,
and yes, I meditate in the morning,
during shelter in place, I'll give a plug
to the insight meditation
center in Redwood City.
And I've been sitting with
Gil, as I say, every morning,
and that's my morning meditation.
And I was saying to my
husband, Rob, earlier today,
my little story about meditation
as I was getting all frazzled,
and kind of grumped at him
and said, "You know, I'm
just trying to grab this
because I have to go sit still with Gil
live at seven o'clock,
I can't, I've gotta be there.
And so it was a moment of
growth for me when I realized,
okay, I've already had my
teaching sort of for this morning
in that I was, you know,
having all of that anxiety
about sitting to get my teaching.
If I just paused I already
had my teaching there.
So my love vignette for
this morning session.
- No, that's great.
I've been I've been dreaming.
Maybe we could still do it in COVID,
creating like a meditation
club in the organization,
we can be two of the starting members
- Yeah,
- That'd be nice
So actually, there's a
question for me about you.
This is interesting.
So from YouTube, Suchinstyle says,
"Sal, why do you find
Marta to be an asset?"
- Oh that's a great question.
- Well, you know, such a great question.
Let me just take a step back, I think,
you know, a lot of times when you imagine,
and actually my brain works,
we've taken like, these personality tests,
and I'm oftentimes skeptical
of personality tests,
because, you know, we can be
different in different cases
but you know, in this case,
I think the personality
test was quite accurate.
Where it said that it
mapped them to colors
is the one we used, but
essentially, I'm red and blue
and that personality test red means
someone who just likes
to, like, get stuff done,
like yesterday as fast as possible.
And then blue is someone who
likes to think, you know,
very big picture, maybe out of the box
and think about what
could the world be like
and dream about it a little bit
and in a lot of ways those are
somewhat stereotypical traits
for people who are entrepreneurial.
You know, they think of these big ideas
and they say, okay,
and I need to try to
build it or prototype it
or work on it tomorrow.
And that was great in the
early days of Khan Academy,
you know, the first four or five years,
it was literally just me
in this walk in closet,
having big, big ideas,
but then also saying,
Let me start hacking this thing together,
let me code it together.
And I didn't have a
background in computer science
but as you grow an organization, you know,
one of the things to really appreciate
is where are your strengths?
And where do you get energy?
And what are your weaknesses?
And where do you not get energy
and there could be weaknesses,
that you just don't have the skills,
you don't have the experience.
And so as Khan Academy has grown,
I have gained ever increasing appreciation
for bringing in people who have
the depth and the experience
to know how to lead teams, scale teams,
have technical depth that I didn't have.
And Marta, I think
exemplifies that and you know,
great people bring in other great people.
So Three, four years ago, Jenny Lee joined
as the president and CEO of Khan Academy.
We'll get Jenny on this,
I think she's being shy.
We'll get Jenny on the live stream soon.
But Jenny, you know, just
as Marta could be a leader
at pretty much any organization
in Silicon Valley or beyond
Jenny as well could.
And then Jenny has helped kind
of provide that consistency,
that process, bringing people along.
If you have 200 folks,
you can't just you know,
my instinct is kind of like,
oh, let's get this done by
this afternoon that done
but if 200 folks they'll just get
we'll be moving in different directions.
So Jenny's provide that leadership
and one of the best
things about leadership
is to bring other really amazing people.
And so Marta was one of the first people
that Jenny brought in and
Jenny knows how to hire
then Marta knows how to hire
and develop and build teams.
We already had a really
good team and it was small
and Marta's been able to
get them to the next level,
but then also put in the processes
and the institutional knowledge
so that people can really make a career
out of being at Khan Academy.
So you know, to answer the
question, what Marta brings,
you know, these projects,
if Marta wasn't here,
and if she wasn't able to lead
the team that she's leading
in the way that she's doing it,
I don't think it's an exaggeration
to say when COVID hit,
a lot of y'all might not have been able
to access Khan Academy (laughs)
I mean, that's just in plain, you know,
and there would have
been millions of people
who would have not been able to learn.
So, because our site probably wouldn't
have been able to scale
or even if it was working,
it would probably take
in 20 seconds for you
to access certain pages,
which would have been very frustrating
for millions of millions of people.
So I think that's one
level and the other thing
which Marta does is, you know,
I have so much confidence
in Marta and her team,
that it allows me to focus more energy
on where I think I might
have value, you know, of,
what's the future of
Khan Academy going to be
where we're going to be
in five years, you know,
I've spent a lot of time fundraising,
I still make a lot of content.
And it's not that I'm detached.
I'm deeply interested and
I want to support Marta
and the team wherever I can
but when you have really amazing leaders,
leaders that you can learn from, you know,
I learned from Marta, I learned from Jenny
and many others every
day about their craft,
about how to lead people,
about how to lead an org.
That just takes a lot off of my plate.
So yeah, I consider myself
very, very fortunate
to have Marta on this team.
- Well, that's very,
very nice of you to say,
and we're very fortunate to be here.
- Oh, thank you. So this is from,
oh, time always runs out
fast when we're having fun,
but we I think we have
time for maybe a few more.
And this is a good question.
And maybe we could both
take a shot at this one
from YouTube, Nico Raj asks,
"How do you face criticism
after having failed at something?"
Marta have you ever failed in anything?
- I have failed in something
every day. (laughs)
- So how did you deal with it?
like, tell me something that you failed,
that kind of hit you.
And maybe even you got criticism.
How did you cope?
- Yeah, that's a great question.
I'll think of one and you
think of one at the same time.
See, if we don't have much time left,
what would be a good one to talk about
I certainly have an abundance
of choices of mistakes
that I make.
I mean, I'm serious when
I say that I make mistakes
all the time.
And I learned from my team all
the time, literally every day
and gain insights from
what folks that are doing.
And let me think of a spectacular failure,
like Yeah, because that's
probably a better story.
- We can compete for largest failures.
- Yeah.
Do you have one you're ready to share?
I'm still--
- Well, I have many.
I mean, from an economic point
of view, people don't know.
So I was working at a hedge fund
and then my boss wanted to retire a
nd he wanted me to essentially
start my own hedge fund.
This was pre Khan Academy.
And I essentially took
over his cost structure,
and I lost and this is, you
know, I didn't own a house,
the only money me and my family had
was essentially a down payment
we were saving up for a house
and I lost almost $200,000.
And so you can imagine our
down payment for a house
quickly became not
sufficient to buy a house.
And so I took long a lot
walks in the hills out here
in Silicon Valley,
trying to save my ego.
And, you know, I would look
at squirrels and I said,
we know that squirrel doesn't
know I just lost $200,000
maybe we can be friends.
And that kind of (laughs)
gave me because it affects you
in very deep ways.
I think we're oftentimes
our biggest critics
and we start saying, you know,
what will my family think of me?
What will my friends think of me?
I've been such a massive failure.
Will I ever be able to recover from this?
Will people ever want to work with me
when they've seen this failure?
Will they hire me?
You know, I mean, there's
really big questions.
You know, in terms of
how do you cope with it,
you realize when you
go through these things
over and over again in
your life, that they pass,
and things do get better,
as long as you put one
foot in front of the other.
And so now that I've had, you know,
I've had probably four or five
of these big failures in my life,
and I've had probably four or 500
of lesser failures in my life,
that in that day also
seemed fairly catastrophic.
I realized that as long as I put one foot
in front of the other,
have a positive attitude,
keep meditating,
a month later, I don't
even remember what that was
or a year later, I can
kind of talk about it
on a live stream like I'm
a you know, a wise soul.
- Yeah, to get back to
our meditation, kind of,
you know, a Buddhist philosophy roots
and mean a big part of
it is just, you know,
the stories we tell ourselves
and so, not believing yourself.
It's true.
I mean, the most important
thing is, we are ourselves.
We're all born as this
pretty perfect little beings
and we do get screwed up along the way
With various things but we are, you know,
that's still there, right?
We all have, you know,
the bad and the good
and we all can get better every day
and so not calling yourself a screw up
or thinking that you screwed up so badly
that no one should love you is
really important way to
leave lead your life, I think
- That's exactly right.
I mean, of the Buddhist or
Eastern or Vedic philosophy,
there's all this notion of non attachment,
that it's only when we get
attached to our personas
or these narratives around our personas
or attached to materiality,
that that's actually the cause
of suffering, true suffering,
you know, there's pain
which is you're getting,
you know, there's a needle in your arm,
there's suffering, which
is the mental state
where you know, you kind
of catastrophize things
and it causes anxiety
but when you realize that, you
know, there's a part of you
that's pure than that,
that is not your persona,
that is not your identity,
that is not your role,
that is not your name, but it's
actually very peace inducing
and liberating and actually helps you
get out of your rut many times.
So not to preach too much.
But Marta, thanks so much.
I mean, there's so many more questions.
I think we will do this again,
if this wasn't a horrible event for you.
(laughs)
But thank you so much for
joining, we will do this again.
And thanks everyone for asking questions.
So, once again, you
know, this is always fun.
We have these great conversations,
I encourage everyone
to join us tomorrow for
ongoing conversations,
and we're gonna be talking
about kind of child development
and how we raise our children
and generational changes.
So thanks, everyone for
joining today's livestream.